[музика]
світові підмостки стали політизованим
місцем після повномасштабного вторгнення
Росії в Україну
[музика]
ну по-перше прибрали з репертуару всю
російську класику всі російські автори
драматурги скасовані
война продовжує війна триває жахливо але
Російська культура за це не відповідає
Не відповідає Антон Павлович Чехов за те
що якийсь божевільні бомбардують
культура це не обов'язково те на що ви
хочете накласти ембарго просто Неможливо
уявити щоб ця людина могла продовжувати
виступати і заробляти на цьому стільки
грошей
причому це ж не йдеться про те що ми
нищимо російську культуру ми просто
ставимо її на паузу
[музика]
[оплески]
шановні глядачі я на цій сцені щоб
сказати що не зможу сьогодні співати я
дізналася що тут є учасник з Росії
тому я не можу співати на одній сцені з
представником терористичної держави
одна лише думка про російські імена та
культуру завдає болю мільйонам українців
від початку загарбницької війни вони
чітко бачать своє майбутнє без всього
російського навколо
[музика]
я любив Чехова Але я розумію що зараз
можна обійтися без нього Привіт я Артем
ямцов артист національного театру імені
Лесі Українки
[музика]
в мене бабуся
Це не рідна це двоюрідна бабуся Це вона
жила в Москві і живе до цих пір ми
перестали з нею спілкуватися що у лютому
минулого року
з моїми всю красоту
до 2013 року всі свої відпустки всі свої
канікули коли вчився в університеті всі
свої відпустки в уже коли працював в
театрі і проводив в Москві я знав весь
репертуар тоді і тут у нас в Києві в
Україні
Це був розвинутий ціком комплекс
меншовартості дуже багато акторів мріяли
грати в Москві приїхати в Москву
зніматися в московських
фільмах серіалах і такий інше
зараз змінилося все
дуже
24 почалася війна
26-го
Одноголосно ми проголосували в нашу шуму
чаті робочому театру Лесі Українки щоб
зняти назву російською драми з назви
театру
всі російські автори драматурги які
колись йшли на цій сцені скасовані
60% репертуар це те що йшло російською
було перекладено українською
непростий момент тому що Як тільки ми
почали перекладатиме це робили самотужки
коли щось треба було з імпровізувати на
сцені Я не міг підібрати таке влучне
слово щоб це було так як колись це було
з російською мовою тому я саме я привів
до театру таку людину і Він виконує
тепер
таку функцію в театрі як викладач
стилістики українською мовою
Уявіть собі що Москва яка зараз бомбить
наші міста вбиває наших людей і після
цього ми приходимо до театру наприклад
на виставу три сестри до цієї три
девочки що кожний 5 хвилин кажуть в
Москву в Москву в Москву в мене
наприклад вже
доводить до бешенства вообще одне слово
Москва для мене це очевидні речі
[музика]
скільки було російських шкіл у тому ж у
Львові які повністю українські
івано-франківську Луцьку Рівному
Тернополі одиничні були випадки
українських шкіл це було російське була
історія комуністичної партії була там І
що якась херня
в мене була українська школа але все
одно була русская литература русский
язык кому він був потрібний в Україні
нащо він був треба
Чому мене вивчали англійську французьку
німецьку чому вивчали цю російську
ідіотську
[музика]
нам
європейська культура світова культура
дала таке
такий багаж цих п'єс
літератури що ми на даний момент можемо
обійтися без Чехова Булгакова
Тургенєва і інших
класиків світової літератури
[музика]
Ми вже в Україні скасували російську
культуру чи можливо це в світі Я не
впевнений тому що
[музика]
не дай Боже але
якщо в світі
пережили те що пережили ми від
Російської
вибачаюсь за слово Федерації
то вони все ж відмовилися від цієї
культури
[оплески]
У той час як російська мова йде з
українських театрів російський режисер
переїжджає в гамбурзький театр
телігається
Я Кирило серебренніков є режисер працюю
в театрі талія як артист резидент про
роль артиста резидента і спектакль
чорний чарнець із спектакль Вій і ось
тепер вистава бароко і далі це такий
великий спектакль блокбастери напевно я
повинен запропонувати артистам акторам
трупі яка тут працює щось незвичайне
якусь сучасну виставу отвій як ми
зробили антивоєнне висловлювання
висказування
[музика]
те що для російського режисера є
антивоєнною заявою для багатьох
українців є провокацією
спектакль Львів розповідає про те як
Троє українських військових беруть у
полон російського солдата вони хочуть
тортурами відплатити йому за вбивство та
згвалтування на сцені з'являється дідусь
який наказує застосувати моральні
тортури солдат повинен читати його
загиблій онуці залишившись з нею
наодинці він відчуває жах на межі між
маранням та реальністю
глядач він також
відчує що мені шкода російських солдат
вони взагалі не мають вибору а в них
взагалі жахливе життя в цій Росії їх
примушують вони бідні їм нема чого
робити як відсилати своїх дітей на війну
а українці взагалі катують російських
солдат
та Привіт Як Катерина демерзає а читанки
Vichy це громадська організація
українців яка працює в Європі і
Німеччині для поширення українських
різних інтересів їхнього представлення
ось і ми організовували протест в
Гамбурзі перед театром талія проти
вистави серебряникова
звичайно жодної симпатії до російського
солдата там не виникає
там я сподіваюся є спектакль із
симпатією до людей взагалі які потрапили
до жахливої ситуації
тим більше історія Там не цілком
конкретна там не називаються жодні
конкретні міста та імена
це історія всередині війни про те як
війна як монстр а безлюднює людей як
важливо незважаючи ні на що залишитися
людиною
я йоахім Люкс художник керівник театру
талія
Я цілком розумію що з українського боку
є Щось на кшталт культури скасування як
ми це називаємо де кажуть що в цей час
не повинно бути Ні Достоєвського ні
Чайковського ні Гоголя ні Чехова
це миттєва емоційна реакція на жахливу
ситуацію
але це політичної культурно дуже погано
і небезпечно
Це абсолютно націоналістичне прочитання
історії яке не працює
причому це ж не йдеться про те що ми
нищимо російську культуру ми просто
ставимо її на паузу не йдеться про те
щоб сидіти спалювати книжки
Достоєвського і товстого так просто
тимчасова пауза щоб зрозуміти і почути
інших
[музика]
матчу
режисер Кирило серебриніков один із
найвизначніших режисерів Росії у нього є
свій театр у гоголь-центр театр який
отримав велику свободу
через його гомосексуальність його
спочатку заарештували через надумані
підстави і погрожували виправно трудовим
табором
а потім посадили на домашній арешт на
кілька років
війна триває жахливо але Російська
культура за це на жаль чи на щастя не
відповідає Не відповідає Антон Павлович
Чехов за те що якийсь Божевільні
бомбардують є якісь люди які намагаються
це пов’язати але це не так Це брехня Це
також маніпуляція
тоже маніпуляція
Пропаганда з обох боків ця Пропаганда та
війна зробили усе щоб людей поділити
були демонстрації були ті які казали не
треба з'єднувати ми навпаки маємо
поділитися Ми не хочемо бачити нічого
російського Ви не повинні чіпати нічого
українського Окей ми все це розуміємо
Тому поки йтиме війна і поки це
відбуватиметься усі ті жахливі події які
відбуваються напевно краще кожному
зайнятися своєю справою
коли кажуть про будування мостів між
українцями і росіянами і запрошують їх у
ці спільні
це все працює лише на руку російській
пропаганді і продовження російської
війни тому що з одного боку це зміщення
уявлення про агресора та жертву розмиває
його частково з іншого боку воно
підтримує уявлення про братні народи
видається що ми маємо протягнути руку і
сказати Давай поговоримо давай будувати
мости Але ж це так не працює якби це так
працювало цієї війни не було
Ми німці Я не знаю як часто ми нападали
на Францію великим досягненням є те що
після Другої світової війни незважаючи
ні на що мир було відновлено на усіх
розломах і українцям звичайно буде дуже
важко привітатися з росіянином Як це має
відбутися але все-таки в якийсь момент
це відбудеться
попри всі дискусії Європа далека від
того щоб скасовувати російську культуру
Але російська пропаганда розпалює страхи
щодо культури скасування
[музика]
на заході лютує вірус на жаль
констатуємо що на заході швидко
прогресує русофобія стихійна катастрофа
так би мовити русофобія стала
невід'ємною частиною західної культури
вони кажуть що російську мову заборонили
Достоєвського і Толстого прибрали з
полиць Чайковського та рахманінова
викреслили з концертних програм але чи є
якісь ліки Всім привіт Мене звати
Валерія ратнікова є журналістка
російського незалежного телеканалу дощ
сьогодні ми поговоримо про нагнітання
страху кремлівської пропагандою щодо
нібито ненависті до всього російського
на заході
гори звісно культура скасування
перетворилася на скасування культури
французькі книгарні прибирають з полиці
усі російські книжки повертають їх
видавцям Я була в Парижі абсолютно
випадково побачила На полиці в одному з
магазинів книгу Сергія Довлатова У мене
є і її фото скажу вам по секрету десь на
полиці є навіть Достоєвський і Толстой
пропагандисти постійно кажуть що
російську класику літератури музики
живопису перестали поважати
вигнання видатних російських музикантів
зі світовим ім'ям гани Нетребко з
міланської ласкала та Маєстро Валерія
георгієва з баварської Державної опери
звичайно жахлива форма русофобії на
заході
ситуація зі співачкою Анною Нетребко
складна у минулому вона підтримувала
президента Путіна і навіть була його
довіреною особою після початку війни
співачка зберігала мовчання до того як
західні майданчики відмовилися з нею
працювати трохи більше ніж через місяць
війни вона таки заговорила Нетребко
написала що категорично засуджує війну в
Україні і що її думки залишаються з
жертвами та їхніми родинами після цього
Нетребко такий скасували концерт але в
Росії через кілька місяців Нетребко
сказала що любить свою країну і
залишається росіянкою Хоча і засуджує те
що відбувається в Росії вона явно хочуть
сидіти на двох стільцях тим не менш
Нетребко живе в Австрії громадянкою якої
вона також є і активно виступає на
Європейських майданчиках як видно з її
нещодавнього розкладу його всесвітньо
відомого диригента захід теж вирішив
скасувати в рамках своєї компанії щодо
скасування всього російського
диригент Валерій геррієв навпаки дійсно
звільнений з посади головного диригента
Мюнхенської філармонії але ось кілька
важливих деталей георгієв активно
підтримував Володимира Путіна на виборах
і виступав перед російськими військовими
в Сирії та в місті тхінвалій в Грузії
20% якого все ще перебуває під
російською окупацією виявляється
диригента Не приймають у Європі зовсім
не тому що він є громадянином Росії а
тому що він підтримує російську агресію
зайдіть на сайт консерваторії чи
оперного театру свого міста і подивіться
чи можна там послухати російську класику
Ось я наприклад у Ризі столиці Латвії
країни Балтії на думку пропагандистів На
сьогоднішній день є найбільш
розофобськими давайте зайдемо на сайт
Латвійської національної опери та балету
і подивимося на репертуар Ми бачимо
Ромео і Джульєтту Сергія Прокоф'єва
Лебедине озеро Петра Чайковського і
навіть Лускунчик на музику того ж
композитора
демократичний концтабір
[музика]
на йогостові фестивальних сцен по всьому
світу ні на Кравіц мабуть найвідоміша
російська технодіджейка але вона також
позувала з картонним Путіним це було у
квітні 2014 року одразу після того як
Росія анексувала Крим чітка заява про
війну в Україні відсутня і сьогодні
якщо ти живеш в Росії платиш податки в
Росії фотографуєшся в центрі Москви і
потім вільно пересуваєшся цим світом то
як художник на сцені що базується на
цінностях свободи та солідарності ти
повинен говорити
Мар'яна Березовська я українська
редакторка і письманиця я пишу про
музику та культуру Я живу в Берліні
Зараз я в Києві в Україні і мені дуже
важливо бути тут і підтримувати свою
громаду прямо зараз під час війни
є заява яку Ніна Кравіц опублікувала у
соцмережах у травні 2022 року
за словами сенеки Римського філософа
стойка державного діяча та драматурга
якщо одна сторона відмовляється
підтримувати ворожнечу то вона згасне
сама по собі
Ну я просто сподіваюся що Ніна розуміє
що насправді тут написано і я просто
хочу нагадати всім включаючи Ніно що це
не двостороння боротьба
це Атака і вона йде з одного боку
Вона йде з Росії і ведеться лише в
Україні де загинуло дуже багато людей
із дуже найчиткою позицією щодо війни І
взагалі щодо влади Путіна для мене
просто Неможливо уявити що ця людина
продовжує виступати і заробляти на цьому
стільки грошей
графік Ніни Кравець залишається
заповненим Хоча вона була виключена з
деяких фестивальних лайнапів у 2022 році
минулого літа вона виступала на сігет
Мене звати тамаш Кадар як генеральний
директор sigad
Я повністю можу зрозуміти якщо українці
були розчаровані цими заявами а також
розумію те що вони в основному не
задоволені тим що бачать її на Лайн апах
різних фестивалів
онлайн
ця жахлива агресія Росії це те що ми і
громада сігету засуджуємо але я не думаю
що ми знаходимося в ситуації коли ми
повинні судити будь-які коментарі чи
будь-які публікації в соціальних мережах
або щось інше від різних артистів які
виступають на фестивалі сігес
Ми вирішили не скасовувати їх бо ми
твердо віримо що культура це не
обов'язково те на що треба вводити
ембарго
триває загарницька війна
і не важливо хто ти букмекер чи фермер
я не можу уявити що хтось не може
висловитися
що ми могли зробити І що ми зробили це
те що ми запросили усіх цих українських
артистів на фестиваль щоб дати їм
можливість висловитися і бути на сцені
Ми також організували збір коштів з цими
артистами та з ініціативою Музика рятує
Україну
Для мене справа не у скасування
російської культури Якщо ви все-таки
хочете презентувати російську культуру
то Будьте ласкаві з митцями які роблять
щось проти російського імперіалізму
[музика]
один із найпомітніших наслідків
російського імперіалізму в усьому
постсоціалістичному просторі вулиці та
площі нагадують у Росію та Радянський
Союз
[музика]
Ми зараз перебуваємо в Берліні в центрі
Олександр плац це дуже відома площа вона
була названа на честь російського
імператора Олександра першого
[музика]
Я звичайно ж приїхала сюди як і напевно
більшість українців бо почалася війна
Мене звати Варя і я хочу назвати вулицю
у Києві на честь свого брата Мій брат
загинув у листопаді під бахмутом
в Україні величезна кількість вулиць
названа на честь російських діячів які
по суті не мають жодного відношення до
української культури а зараз ще ці імена
асоціюються з війною Та терором ми
хочемо саме цю вулицю Це вулиця
салтикова-щедріна Тобто це вулиця на
Печерську де він жив перейменувати на
честь Сергія Миронова
до війни до війни діяльність Сергія була
пов'язана з Києвом він був його
хранителем таким ангелом як кажуть його
підписники він займався реставрацією
дверей і в принципі під'їздів якихось
плиток йому було Це дуже цікаво і він
проводив екскурсії Києвом він є автором
відомого блогу Бені шинкиєв який
присвячений суто Києву і вже з моменту
війни присвячений військовим щоденникам
його навіть інколи називають українським
ремарком
українським ремарками
повітряної тривоги
зникаючи Київ зникаючий Київ він писав
про ці старовинні будинки і всі які в
майбутньому планував реставрувати якось
знаходити якийсь бюджет у нього була
колосальна кількість планів
[музика]
він взагалі не про війну у нас же Які
хлопці йдуть на війну
[музика]
в коха
нні такої приложение є такий додаток
Київ цифровий незважаючи на те що
йдеться про Київ усі українці голосують
і це найважливіший щабель далі після
цифрового голосування йде Київрада
Київрада
якби Сергій знав що ми зараз прокручуємо
навколо нього реакція була в
катастрофічна ми б усі отримали просто я
не знаю він дуже скромний і йому не дуже
сподобалося що ми просимо за нього
взагалі щось це маячня просто в голові
не вкладається він би сказав
[музика]
зміна мови не відбувається відразу
У мене є пісня поховай в собі росіянина
Мені потрібно поховати його Бо інакше я
не зможу повернути свою справжню рідну
ідентичність
[музика]
Мене звати Дінара Я народилася в казанії
і зараз живу в Берліні Я пишу вірші та
прозу а також проводжу мовні семінари
Казань столиця татарстану Автономної
Республіки у складі Російської Федерації
я розмовляла татарською до 6 років
коли я пішла в школу в Казані а в Казані
в 1990-х роках були переважно
російськомовні школи То дуже скоро Я
почала забувати свою мову і перейшла на
російську
свешивается
Дыхание коли я пішла до школи то
виявилося що говорити по-татарськи
нібито соромно тут
і це було така парадигма що російська
мова це мова крутих дітей великої
літератури а Татарська це мова селян і
фермерів
Village
і це теж подавалося як щось погане і
неправильне
[оплески]
Story те саме історія з багатьма
культурами не лише курінних жителів
Північної Росії а й інших країн які були
в СРСР наприклад я розмовляла з
українцями з білорусами
немає рідної мови немає рідної мови
Якщо завтра моя мова помре кімната Без
вікон
на цьому воркшопі у мене було 12 чи 14
людей і всі вони почали використовувати
свої мови і я хочу переконати їх
повірити що вони можуть писати своїми
рідними мовами навіть якщо вони дуже
обмежено знають ці мови які я
шпаха Російська Мова - це та мова якою я
думаю частково працюю та іноді пишу
Мене звати салтонат шушанова Як вір
феміністка Я родом з Казахстану і зараз
живу в Берліні
привіт з вами подкаст хз Мене звати Лена
баришева а мене салтонан шушенова
який стосується ідентичностей різних
історій і приналежності більшості на
пострадянському просторі до східної
Європи плюс цього року ми запустили
спінооф російською мовою
Привіт Мене звати Юлія бокслер я
подкастирка режисерка і працює в команді
trexist
Ми боялися Чесно кажучи Ми готувалися до
того що якщо ми запустимо подкаст
російською то нас теж можуть скасувати
через критикувати тому що ми б теж це
зрозуміли в деякій мірі але нічого з
цього не сталося взагалі нічого
Я вважаю що плитка з хазяй російською
мовою з'явився вчасно Я хочу
використовувати цей подкаст як таку
платформу щоб почути Цей голос і
зрозуміти що з нами відбувається в цей
момент коли триває ця війна і де
російська мова використовується як зброя
однією стілею нашого російськомовного
спінофу було сформулювати контрнератив
російською мовою в цій країні звісно є
люди які тут теж переважно споживають
російськомовні ЗМІ і ми просто хочемо
запропонувати невеликий альтернативний
канал із просуванням демократії та
освітнім контентом
[музика]
мені зараз важливо сказати це моя мова і
це не мова пропаганди
це не мова Путіна це не мова війни